hey 42 here a snail can sleep for more
than three years at a time welcome to
RIF in the video game Paper Mario the
thousand-year door there was a playable
transgender character called Vivienne
who had a subplot about being accepted
by her family
this was censored out of the American
version there is a word prone area which
is the opposite of paranoia it's the
belief that everything in the universe
is conspiring to support you in 1938
Time magazine named Adolf Hitler man of
the year two days after announced dies
it gives off an odor which / ants are
drawn to they come in pick up the ant
and carry it to a designated ant
graveyard
Oreos ripped off a cookie called Hydrox
which were invented in 1908 but they
went out of business in 2008 birds
cannot go into space because they can't
swallow without gravity heed heed Rick
the man who invented frisbees was
cremated and made into a frisbee after
he died
wikipedia bans the Church of Scientology
from editing any articles following a
string of deceptive edits on various
articles from the church u.s. President
James Buchanan would regularly buy
slaves in Washington then take them to
Pennsylvania and quietly set them free
in Finland speeding tickets are
calculated based on a percentage of a
person's income meaning some Finnish
millionaires have received speeding
tickets of up to 90,000 euro 78% of NFL
players are bankrupt within two years
after finishing their careers humans
have had dogs as companions for more
than 14,000 years if you eat a polar
bears liver you will die of a vitamin A
overdose Rastafarians are legally
allowed to possess marijuana in Italy
due to it being a sacrament to their
religion if you drop a tarantula it will
shatter they have extremely fragile
exoskeletons thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42